mha just went all out the most popular
character in the entire series is back
from the dead all the major players are
now at the scene of the final battle the
entire world is watching and then those
twists a Twist at the beginning of the
chapter and a Twist at the end of the
chapter this was crazy so let's get into
it you guys know how this works if you
enjoy my M videos and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
and comment right now for that YouTube
algorithm and if you want to help this
channel attain Quirk Singularity by
hitting 2 million subscribers do me a
big favor and subscribe right now we are
so close finally this video will of
course contain mha manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned now the previous chapter
confirmed that basically all the other
villains aside from shigaraki for one
were successfully neutralized by the
heroes which means that all eyes are now
on all for one and she got a keep
and what do you know all for one just
arrived to the very place where Deku
versus shigaraki is unfolding since he
was now close enough Al foran tried to
use the gloop warp Quirk to teleport
shigaraki to his location so that he can
complete his takeover of shigaraki's
body but shigaraki successfully resisted
the teleportation attempt all for one
then realized that he will have to go
right up to shigaraki In the Flesh and
force him to ingest the copy of the 0
for one Quirk that for onean still
possesses and this should break down
shigaraki's willpower and allow all
foran to take over permanently but all
for one couldn't help himself from
tormenting the heroes along the way so
he decided to grab the injured all might
and carry him through the air as a way
of showing dein the other Heroes that
their precious symbol of peace has been
defeated and that he is about to die
this decision by the villain allowed all
might to make one final sacrifice he
used the the one final piece of armor
that he still had a gauntlet on his left
arm to grab all for one by the neck he
then initiated the process of
self-destructing The Gauntlet in an
attempt to cause an explosion that will
kill all for one even if all for one can
recover from this injury he will likely
be the age of a kindergartener after he
regenerates which means that he will no
longer be a threat to the heroes now
naturally the armorless and quirkless
all might expected to die from this
explosion as well
but he felt that this sacrifice was
worth making for the sake of the next
generation of Heroes at the end of the
last chapter it was hard to imagine that
all might could survive an explosion of
this kind at such close range and so we
all began saying our goodbyes to the
Legendary Heroes even deu started to cry
as he realized that all might is about
to die and yet he couldn't go and help
his mentor because shigaraki promised
that if Deku leaves him to help help Al
might he will go back to UA and murder
all of deku's friends who were still
there the latest chapter is called the
end of an era and dot dot dot and it
starts off with a young all might
reading the anpan Man manga with his
mother little toshinori appears to be
only like 5 years old at this point and
he looks like an extremely happy child
that is kind of the point because all
might says that his childhood was very
normal and that he doesn't have a proper
hero origin story meaning that he
doesn't have a tragic backstory that can
explain exactly why he became the hero
he is today that said though after
meeting Nana a high school-aged toshino
did say that his parents were killed so
clearly he did have some tragic moments
in his childhood now maybe his parents
weren't killed by villains and died some
other way or maybe he just meant that
his early childhood was normal but then
later some tragic stuff did happen
either way all might believes that the
path he chose along the way was very
important and it led him to becoming the
man that he is today PS yes his mom was
hot and I couldn't live with myself if I
didn't bring that up so drop a like for
all might's hot mom right now back in
the present we learned that the ending
of the previous chapter was a bit
misleading in that final panel it seemed
like the explosion all might activate
through his Gauntlet was inevitable and
that this was basically it for all might
however it turns out that just before
the explosion happened a bunch of spikes
emerged from all foran's body and they
tore through both all might's arm and
The Gauntlet itself because these spikes
then destroyed the gauntlets mechanisms
it failed to self-destruct and so the
explosion did not happen this means that
both all might and Al for one are in
fact still alive although all might is
still extremely injured and now his left
arm is useless because it was stabbed
clean through by multiple spikes he is
now basically at all for one's mercy and
that in itself is extremely bad but it
gets even worse it turns out that all
for one did succeed in stealing stains
Quirk and he proceeds to lick some of
all my's blood which activates stains
Quirk and completely paralyzes all might
as all for one's face morphs into an
extremely wide stain likee grin
potentially as some sort of side effect
of stain squirk the villain explains
that he knows how dangerous a wounded
hero can be so he wasn't about to take
any chances yes he did leave all might
alive for now but he took precautions
and so all might's attempt to get one
over and all for one even at the cost of
his own life was a failure all might is
now severely injured armorless quirkless
and completely paralyzed so now he can
only be a helpless spectator of all for
one's master plan in action say what you
will about all for one but he is
definitely a truly Dev previous villain
and unlike so many cliche villains in
anime and manga all for one does not
underestimate his opponents which is
something I appreciate side note but all
for once face with that wide unnatural
grin is clearly a reference to the Joker
from The Dark Knight so yeah Hoshi is
added again with the references
meanwhile gentle is out there still
using his Quirk to keep the UA from
floating and he is of course still being
powered up by La Brava now that the
twice clone have disappeared the UA is
able to float on its own so gentle
decides to leave the UA and try to help
all might however before that can happen
all for one just casually shoots a laser
attack at the floating building
crippling its flotation systems and
forcing gentle to stay at his post the
jet Squadron that fought with star and
stripe also joins the fight and they try
to attack all for one and help all might
they want to honor star's memory by
protecting her Idol and greatest role
model but unfortunately even with
futuristic fighter jets under their
command the Squadron is helpless against
all for one he easily annihilates all of
them and sends them crashing to the
ground poor Admiral Akbar he really
should have known it was a trap yes yes
I know all of this looks really bad for
all might but then again I've been
saying the same thing for the past
several chapters and yet here we are
he's still alive so that's something we
have to keep in mind mind that said
suuki deu and many people throughout the
world who are watching the fight are
increasingly concerned and desperate as
they witness what looks to be the
complete and utter defeat of the symbol
of peace Melissa Gran Torino and a bunch
of others are also watching and you can
literally see the pain on their faces at
this point all for one is holding a
helpless and paralyzed all might over
his head as deu and suoi and the others
cry and pray and scream some someone
someone please help all might someone
someone and then at the very end of the
chapter we see that someone emerging
from the smoke that rises from the
floating UA that person is none other
than bakugo I mean bakugo but yes he is
back he still looks pretty bloodied and
quite injured but he is standing on his
feet and he is still holding his
allmight hero card that he andu first
got his kids all those years ago
it seems that Ed shot's magic bubble
heart surgery thingy worked and bakugo
is not only alive and well but he is
also apparently ready to continue the
fight the final page shows both bakugo
and deu looking Fierce with fire in
their eyes and the narrator declares
that yes this is the end of an era and
the beginning of a new one in fact if
you look closely bakugo's eyes look a
lot like they did in the second m ha
movie when he briefly gained the ability
to use one for all which is very
interesting could this mean that deu is
about to share one forall with bakugo
once again and will that be the thing
that puts the heroes over the edge and
allows them to finally win against the
villain and speaking of putting the
heroes over the edge did Ed shot's
procedure give bakugo extra powers that
we don't know about yet that whole
procedure thing was really weird it was
implied that Ed shot would have to like
start living inside of bakugo's heart or
body or something so is bakugo going to
inherit some of Ed shot's Powers
definitely let me know what you guys
think down in the comments below now if
you've been watching my mha videos then
you know that for a long time I've been
speculating about the potential for deu
to reach Quirk Singularity and for one
for all to evolve even further during
the final battle against shigaraki I
even did a video where I talked about
deu po potentially unlocking a secret e
Quirk and I thought that this Quirk
might be a sort of one forall
Singularity where all the different
quirks within one for all merge into one
single super Quirk that way deu wouldn't
have to keep switching between different
quirks all the time he could just use
one Quirk that possesses all of the
powers of the other quirks at once and
perhaps even more Powers because of how
all those different quirks could merge
and combine in extremely interesting
ways but now seeing bakugo's eyes
looking like they did in the second
movie I started wondering if deku's
secret eighth Quirk could be something
else what if one for all evolves to a
point where it can be shared with
multiple other people including bakugo
and maybe even some other students
within class 1a and what if that is how
the heroes ultimately end up beating
shigaraki through some insane oneforall
powered teamwork I mean think about it
the Quirk is called called one for all
so it would be interesting if its
ultimate power turned out to be a way to
share it with a bunch of different
overpowered hero students in order to
create an entire mini army of One for
All users this would definitely be a
great way to bring home the message that
all might has been pushing for so many
chapters the idea that he believes in
all of his students not justu that he
believes all of them will be the new
symbols of peace that he believes all of
them will become the greatest Heroes and
that is why he went out of his way to
pay tribute to all of their quirks with
his armor what do you guys think will
the final battle end with deu the one
Awakening the power to share his Quirk
with all and will this then allow the
next generation of Heroes to defeat
shigaraki together now that we know that
all might is still somehow alive will he
actually live to see the end of the
final battle and the end of the story
itself let me know down below we need to
get a good conversation going how do you
feel about bakugo's return and what's
next in the story if you're looking for
a refresher about all the different
class 1a quirks and their powers I made
an entire video about that very topic
link on screen and in the description if
you enjoyed this MJ video and you want
to see more in the future leave a quick
like to let me know and if you want to
help us attain Quirk Singularity on this
channel by hitting 2 million subscribers
do me a big favor and subscribe right
now we are so close